die Gedanken dass jetzt hier was
passieren könnte darf man glaube ich
auch nicht haben ob ich jetzt mich
dadurch sicherer fühle kann ich nicht
sagen weil wenn was passiert passiert
wirklich was leider man sollte einfach
mal ein
bisschen ein bisschen optimistischer
einfach in die Zukunft
gucken mehr als 2500 Weihnachtsmärkte
gibt es in Deutschland 1500 davon gelten
als so groß dass sich
Menschenansammlungen bilden alleine auf
dem Hamburger Rathausmarkt sind es in
der Adventszeit rund 3 Millionen
Besucher die eine unbeschwerte
Vorweihnachtszeit
genießen Sicherheitsexperten aber sehen
nicht die entspannte Stimmung sondern
die potenziellen Gefahren verstärkt auch
durch den Krieg in
narost und die Amas jeden Tag fordert
ihre Anhänger dazu auf hier auch im
Ausland auch in Europa auch in
Deutschland was sie Widerstand nennen zu
leisten aber was natürlich jeder
versteht es geht hier drum Gewalt
auszuüben um eben den Druck auf die
Regierung zu erhöhen praktisch wiederum
Israel zu zwingen diesen Konflikt oder
diesen Angriff zu
beenden Weihnachtsmärkte in Deutschland
so hat es das
Bundesinnenministerium bereits
öffentlich festgestellt sind ein
potenzielles
Anschlagsziel spricht die
Ermittlungsbehörden haben die Märkte
besonders im
[Musik]
Blick dieser achsmarkt liegt in Hamburg
direkt an der Elbe die Einrichtung ist
wie viele Weihnachtsmärkte überall in
Deutschland frei zugänglich für jeden
egal mit welchen
Absichten ich habe ja in den letzten
Monaten fast gebüsmöenartig immer D vor
gewarnt es gibt sowas wie absolute
Sicherheit nicht und der islamistische
Terror ist nicht
weg abstrakt hohgefahr ist immer noch da
und kann leider jederzeit auch konkret
werden und deswegen müssen wir die Augen
schon offen halten auch was unsere
Weihnachtsmärkte angeht eine abstrakte
Gefahr aber hat das wirklich Einfluss
auf die Menschen vor Ort lassen sich die
Weihnachtsmarktbesucher die Stimmung von
betonpollern
vermießen die Lage ob das jetzt bei uns
hier vor Ort ist sage ich mal oder in
der weiten Welt gerade auch Israel und
so macht ein schon so ein bisschen
beklemmend aber man kann sich nicht von
allem immer so mitnehmen lassen sondern
man soll auch wirklich mal das genießen
was man eigentlich hat ja sicherlich ist
es eine Abwechslung von dem Alltag was
man sonst so hat und so weiter V ist man
deswegen auch in der anderen Umgebung ne
wenn man sonst
normalerweise weihnachtswei in der Firma
oder in im Büro wäre glaube ich relativ
langweilig deswegen hier mal eine
Abwechslung eine Flucht würde ich das
nicht bezeichnen klar man blendet
natürlich einiges aus und lässt sich
einfach gut gehen und ich glaube wir
muss das Verdienen ne und man muss das
auch einfach damit ein das gut geht
manchmal die klein Ding im Leben oder
genau ja
und die genießt man dann genau wenn man
nur das Schlechte sieht dann geht's am
irgendwann auch schlecht es läuft nicht
so ganz rund tatsächlich in der Welt und
umso wichtiger dass man unter Kollegen
Kolleginnen einfach einen schönen
schönen Moment
hat seit dem Anschlag auf dem Berliner
Breitscheidplatz 2016 finden
Großveranstaltungen hinter polland statt
Betonsperren und Stahlstreben sollen
Fahrzeuge ab halten Lieferwagen
versperren Einfahrten private
Sicherheitsdienste
kontrollieren das größte Volksfest im
Norden der Hamburger Dom hat im Winter
eine Million Besucher die Schausteller
stellen dabei fest dass die Besucher
wenig Gedanken an mögliche Gefahren
verschwenden wer diese Welt betritt legt
für 2 3 Stunden den Alltag zur Seite
gefahren
ausgeblendet ich kann mir vorstellen
dass man vielleicht kurz vor dem Besuch
mal einmal drüber nachdenkt und wenn man
das nicht hört diese Themen die Sie
angesprochen haben dann machen wir alles
richtig dann gehe ich hierher um den
Kopf frei zuukriegen schalt einfach mal
ab genieß die Zeit mit meinen Lieben mit
meiner Familie mit meinen Freunden und
mach einfach nur mal was ich möchte
abschalten genießen und auf sich
zukommen
lassen doch wie konkret manche Planungen
sein können zeigte sich Ende November in
Köln 201 15 und 16 Jahre alte
Jugendliche sollen dort Anschläge auf
einen Weihnachtsmarkt und eine Synagoge
geplant haben
so stand es in Chats die die
Ermittlungsbehörden verfolgen
konnten Problem für Terrorgruppen ist
natürlich immer für ihre Unterstützer
für ihre Finanziers wenn sie aus der
Berichterstattung fallen und im Moment
redet ganz Deutschland ganz Europa die
ganze Welt aus schließlich mehr oder
weniger über Hamas also muss auch der
islamische Staat wiederum versuchen hier
in Deutschland oder Europa eine Aktion
zu machen die sie wieder auf die Agenda
bringt deshalb hatten wir die Verhaftung
des einen Herren der da Versuch
eine israelische Demonstration mit einem
Auto zu rammen und die Verhaftung dieser
Jugendliche die wohl überlegt haben auch
hier auf Weihnachtsmärkte anchläge zu
üben moin nicht erschrecken die
Hamburger Polizei erstmal guten Appetit
für Sie zur Info wir haben viele
Taschendiebe Tasche Rucksack genau ist
hinten ziemlich los nach vorne immer für
die Polizisten auf den Märkten wie hier
auf St Pauli in Hamburg heißt das neben
dem normalen Betrieb immer auch auf
Besonderheiten achten und
ausstrahlen also grundsätzlich auf
Weihnachtsmarkt gehe ich z einfach
gerne ich weiß nicht fin das eigentlich
ganz schön wenn man wenn man hier so
rüber geht ich finde das fördert eher
zum Teil so ein bisschen das
weihnachtsfeling tatsächlich ne also wir
gehen ja nun hier lang und es ist alles
schön geschmückt und glaube jeder der in
der Innenstadt arbeitet weiß dass man
halt auch auf dem Weg nach Hause und zum
Dienst ne es ist alles ganz schön
geschmückt das ist schon echt nett muss
ich sagen zum Einsatz und
Sicherheitskonzept auf den
Großveranstaltungen dürfen die
sagen klar ist nur sie reagieren auf
jede Auffälligkeit einmal anhalten
bitte moin ja ja was los bei Ihnen ganz
viel Leute
an ja aber deswegen möchten andere Leute
vielleicht trotzdem von
Ang ja das egal ab nicht aber sind ganz
schön betrunken das ist nicht gut wie
ist denn ihr Plan für
heute doch aberlich wenn sie andere le
alsoentweder aufhören zu trinken oder
sie Haken sich beim Freund ein
vielleicht ja das ist hier dass ohne
Leute gerade wieder laufen können
ja man hat ja gesehen er hat hier
mehrere Leute angerempelt die er aufens
nicht kennt und wir wollen natürlich
dass sie alle wohlfühlen und dann
sprechen wir schon mal mit den Leuten
weil es macht ja sonst keiner keiner
spricht ja gerne irgendwelche fremden
betrunkenen Menschen an und das
natürlich unser Job und dann haben wir
immer gesagt dass er ein bisschen
aufpassen soll er hat die bei einem
Kumpel eingehakt der ihn so ein bisschen
führt dass er hier nicht irgendwie noch
ein Streit gerätt mit irgendjemanden
oder
so das subjektive Sicherheitsgefühl soll
so scheint es möglichst hoch sein auf
der Hamburger Reperbahn sind ohnehin
viele Beamte unterwegs sie zeigen
Präsenz und schauen sich die Zugänge an
allerdings ist es derzeit auch rund um
Hamburg son zu beliebten
Touristenmagneten auf St Pauli eher
ruhig selbst auf reerbahn ist gar nicht
mehr so viel los also die die große
Freiheit große Freiheit ist eigentlich
der der place to be am Wochenende und
selbst im Hamburger Berg hat's auch
abgenommen ja also nur noch diese
kleinen Kneipen aber das Gro also ich
wür sagen 80% der Leute sind wirklich
wenn sie feiern wollen hier in in der
Großen Freiheit auch dieser Bereich des
Hamburger Vergnügungsviertels ist mit
versenkbaren stahpllern versehen die
Aufmerksamkeit der Besucher richtet sich
ohnehin auf andere Bereiche überhaupt
sind die stankt paulianer sehr
aufmerksam wenn es um ihren Stadtteil
geht schräge Typen gibt es hier ohnehin
genug die schnell merken wenn etwas
nicht stimmt die aber auch gerne sich in
den Mittelpunkt drücken wir haben
einfach ganz viel sehr starke Charaktere
hier auf die werden hier angezogen und
die Leben hier und muss man lernen
klarzukommen wenn man hier arbeitet aber
meistens kann man mit den ganzpann
umgehen und dann gehen die irgendwann
vielle
weiter undan D gehen zurü auf
Weihnachsmarkt bodenplatz die
Polizeibeamten zeigen Präsenz und halten
die Augen
offen an der
gesamtbedrohungslage können sie nichts
ändern das müssen die Geheimdienste und
Verfassungsschutzbehörden im Blick
haben wir haben hier in Deutschland
mehrere hundert Hamas Unterstützer oder
auch Anhänger wir haben mehrere hundert
Gefährder aus dem islamistischen Bereich
aus dem rechtsextremen Bereich und
gefährde sind ja Personen die jederzeit
bereits in Gewalt auszüben und da gibt
es dann die Notwendigkeit jeden Tag
Prioritäten zu treffen wer hier
überwacht wird wir haben gesehen gerade
bei der Verhaftung in
nordrinwestfalen dieser jungen Personen
die da verhaftet worden sind dass
natürlich die europäische Kooperation
super funktioniert ja wir sind jetzt
wirklich auch so dass alle Dienste
überall hingucken und sich gegenseitig
helfen das ist die gute Nachricht aber
kein System der Welt wird einen
Einzeltäter oder alle Einzeltäter immer
in jedem Fall auch aufhalten können die
Fr haben schon mehrfach sehr sehr
schmerzhaft erfahren die Belgier vor
kurzem als es diese Ermordung der zwei
belgischen Staatsbürger gab in Brüssel
es wird immer wieder leider dazu kommen
dass Einzeltäter eben auch Anschläge
fen viel mehr Sorge bereitet den
Ermittlern der Einsatz von Drohnen die
kleine Lasten tragen können solche
Planungen finden sich im Internet dabei
geht es nicht um direkten Schaden
sondern darum Panik auszulösen die
bislang bekannt gewordenen anschlagpläne
auf smärkte sah Sprengstoff als Mittel
zum Zweck vor die Behörden haben bislang
frühzeitig eingegriffen eines aber ist
klar Großveranstaltungen sind sensible
Ziele auch Weihnachtsmärkte bleiben also
Advent hinter
Betonsperren